can you talk to us about how la has
inspired you haunted you but I wasn't
thinking to make a movie about Los
Angeles but when I read the story it
felt like I had so many elements to be
an entertaining and interesting movie
and and it couldn't be set anywhere else
the fact that they were living over the
hill from all these stars was such a
part of the story so it la did become a
character in the movie and I really
wanted to capture you know the setting
and make you feel like you're really
there with them and wanted to show the
you know the kind of LA architecture and
the glimmering lights and the distance
and um it's just the headquarters of
this part of our culture when I buy the
story I thought I was so fascinating how
how different it was then when I was
growing up and how they're so they have
access to so much information and and
they you know know so much about these
kind of grown-up things so you blame the
Internet it's pretty it's a pretty
particular story but um these kids were
really immersed in you know tabloid
culture that um you know and it's yeah
but not all teenagers not like that
let's hope speaking of the particular
story you diverged a little from the
Vanity Fair story can you talk about at
what points you did and why I met the
journalist and she gave me all her
transcripts and I really based on my
material on what she had gathered and
then I also met some of the real kids
and what was that like it was
interesting mostly um when I met the boy
he told me a lot of stories and and gave
me little details that um could help me
understand their mindset and then I put
in the story and just talked about how
they Connor was stealing cars in this
casual way and when he told me that the
main girl wanted to steal Paris Hilton's
dog I thought but just things like that
I couldn't makeup so it was really
interesting to hear the real the real
parts of the story when we filmed at
Paris Hilton's house that was really her
real house that she let us foeman and I
couldn't imagine anything like that so
it was pretty you didn't have to dress
the set at all now that one everything
else was invented but that was really
her house too that was
pretty unbelievable to see cuz and there
was a nightclub room and yeah I'd heard
about our nightclub room so to see her
real nightclub room was pretty amazing
and then you know and then you see that
you put the kids in that environment of
course they're going to react to it so
that was you know that was funny I
wanted to show them hanging out in her
room but you know you give them a Paris
Hilton pillow and see what happens
can you take us through the process of
why it took so long and how your casting
decisions were made yeah my casting team
spent a year meeting every young actor
we just wanted to get the the strongest
team and and it's always exciting to
discover new actors and when it's really
an ensemble like that you need to have
them you know strong actors that can
also balance a whole group and have
different personalities so so yeah we
met a lot of people and Fred Bruce my
producer who has a has a knack for
finding young talent um helped me and
and some of these because it was our
first film and then Emma Watson of
course is very experienced but I would
have never thought of her in this type
of role but um they met her the valley
accent down really well yeah she worked
really hard and was very specific about
that Calabasas accent so uh it was fun
to watch her transform and take it so
seriously we did rehearsals and had them
spend time together in the weeks before
shooting and they would do all their
fittings together and Clara the blonde
girls were a real la girl and she took
them around and then I I had them watch
movies that glamorized robbery is to get
them in that like which one like Ocean's
eleven and I'm Thomas Crown Affair and
you just kind of try to make it look fun
and getting the mindset of these these
kids who were you know thinking of it as
a as a thrill and and then I had them
I had a friend leave their house one
night in Hollywood Hills and they snuck
had to sneak in and find things with a
good burglars they were and and and
their whole kind of group dynamics
started to come out as they were
fighting over things or you know how
they acted in that situation it helped
in the scene I have a technical question
does no one in Los Angeles use burglar
alarms I mean that was the most striking
thing to me we saw the burglar alarms on
the walls yeah
in the real story they didn't break in
today the houses they just snuck in
windows they didn't actually break any
doors and I think there's just a kind of
a lacks attitude that you know nothing
Bad's really gonna happen that's a lie
yeah and I know this was shot partially
by the late Harris survives can you talk
about what it was like to work with him
he worked with you on somewhere I never
shot digitally before so when he told me
he thought we should shoot it digitally
I trusted him because I knew he could
always make anything look beautiful and
uh you know it was trepidatious to to
make it change because I loved film so
much and and he you know helped set the
look and the the feeling of the film and
um and just gave it um you know a
beautiful quality in a setting that's
you know not not so beautiful and you
know in low-light situations you had a
little more flexibility and I just feel
like you you want to shoot each film in
the style of the subject matter and this
one it really suited it because there
you know it's immediate and they're
shooting on phones and we're mixing
surveillance footage so in that it felt
like the right medium for the story and
in this film I wanted it to really have
the energy of the kids and music they'd
be listening to and just that the thrill
ride of having that the audience
experience this this ride that they're
on